[Music]
hi everybody my name is markiplier and
I'm officially back from Las Vegas if
you missed out and didn't check Facebook
and Twitter or anything you may not have
noticed that I was actually gone because
I had uploaded videos automatically for
the past week straight but I am now back
so thank you guys so much for sticking
with me in the gap um I just literally
walked in the door turned on my computer
and start recording so I don't really
have anything planned to say um if I had
to say anything thank you guys so much
for the birthday wishes and everything
that you did last week hope you had a
great 4th of July for your American if
not hope you enjoyed doing whatever it
is you would do on a Thursday night was
it I had a great time in Vegas I did ton
of stuff I'm mega super ultra tired and
have not changed I am the stanky as ever
in my awesome Planet Express shirt that
someone gave me and what else am I gonna
say hmm I really got nothing else to do
oh I won in the gambling thing I threw
money down on a slot machine and a poker
thing and I won like a lot and then I
spent it immediately on shows there I
saw sarcana and the Blue Man Group both
works were autumn if you saw my tweet
about the Blue Man Group I high-fived a
robot and now I'm just rambling about
random stuff that you probably don't
care about but either way thank you guys
so much for being with me and supporting
me um there I didn't meet any fans down
there mostly because I didn't tell
anyone where I was so if you happen to
run into me on the streets I was hoping
that you know that would happen but
where you can meet me and it's far too
late to know about this now for you to
do anything if you weren't already going
already but I'm going to comic-con in a
week or two week and a half I think it
starts on the 16th 17th 15th I'm not
sure I've got another week to prepare I
will be doing uploads pre-recorded
uploads for that as well but I will also
be v logging every day or vlogging
whatever you want to call it so that you
guys know what's going on on the
showroom floor so that you guys can
interact with me and hunt me down and
find me also because you are going to
hunt them down and find me I'm gonna
make it a little easier for you because
I will be at the Keene spot booth most
of the time if you don't know what
Keynes Bhat is it's a webcomic
a company that my brother is a part of
they're kind of like you know just an
ensemble of multiple different web
comics that are pretty awesome my
brothers won't probably think is their
biggest one and that's why I got invited
out there last year and so if you guys
are at comic-con in San Diego California
this year in two weeks time then you can
meet me there
where I will probably be then since I'm
gonna be there for about four days
straight your chances are pretty good of
finding me and then doing whatever
you've had planned to do with me
whatever that may be for the time being
so thank you all so much for watching
thank you for joining me and thank you
for supporting me even though I wasn't
even here so thank you guys again hope
you're having a great weekend I'm gonna
go take a nap cuz I'm a little hyped up
on energy drinks and not feeling quite
myself but I had a great vacation sorry
it was a little spontaneous but my
friends really wanted to go out and
they've been planning it for about uh
half a year now so thanks again
everybody hope to see you in Comic Con
if I don't then I will be vlogging and
maybe one of you will be in my one of my
good old vlogs there so thanks again
everybody for watching thank you I've
already said thank you like ten times
I'm gonna keep singing until it gets
annoying so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video